Hello everyone, you all must have just heard a news
about the tentacle element that
some of its traces have been found in the basin of our Sutlej river, so
why
is tentacle so special, then we will
know its uses. Actually, what is tentacle?
Its atomic number is 73 and it is a very
rare metal. It is used in capacitors and
many electronic
devices. Support capacity is good. Secondly, it is
very hard, that is why it is
also used in making turbine blades, supersonic jet nozzles and now it is used in surgical tools and equipment.
Implants because it is chemically inert
and it is a very rare metal and is
also very important, so its
availability in our country is a big thing.